Tick Tock is full of beauty hacks so I
gathered some of the most hype texts to
test out for myself
the first hack is using a makeup sponge
to stamp on a super easy rainbow
eyeshadow look I am terrible at applying
eyeshadow so maybe this will make the
process easier and hopefully a little
faster so we're gonna work from the
outer Corner in and we're gonna start
with purple
[Music]
okay now what I'm gonna do is take a
Q-tip and some micellar water and just
clean it up and create a sort of wing
shape now I'm going to take my black
eyeliner and just outline the shape that
I made I wouldn't say this hack was
super successful for me but I honestly
think the biggest problem with it was
the eyeliner and that's not even really
part of the hack to me the hack is using
the sponge to apply the eye shadow and
that actually worked pretty well I felt
like it gave you really good color
payoff it does get a bunch of Shadow
everywhere but I think that's when your
pinching method has to come in handy you
got to make it like really small at the
top like that even though the eyeliner
part was apparently a little too
advanced for me I think I would
definitely use a sponge to stamp on
eyeshadow again the next hack is
applying press-on nails with gel glue to
make them last longer so instead of
using a regular nail glue I'm using a
gel which you cure with a UV lamp using
the gel glue is definitely going to make
this a lengthy process but if it makes
the press-ons last longer I really don't
mind my press-ons pop off after a few
days usually I would say four to five
days so to start I'm going to apply a
base gel to all my nails and cure for 90
seconds going One Nail at a time I'm
gonna apply a thin layer of gel glue on
my actual nail and also put some inside
of the Press on working from the cuticle
forward I'm applying the Press on with
even consistent pressure to avoid any
air bubbles and Flash curing that for 15
seconds while still applying pressure
after applying each nail I'm curing all
of them for 90 seconds I'm gonna finish
it off with a thin layer of gel top coat
and cure that for 90 seconds I feel like
I never know how much glue is the right
amount of glue like I just keep adding
too much but then when I don't add too
much I add too little and the nail just
comes off
you definitely have to do this process
more than once I feel like to get
comfortable with all the products and
steps that you have to go through but
once you do get it I think the nails
feel really good it's been almost two
weeks and these press-ons are still
going strong I cannot believe I've never
tried this hack before it's so good
again it does take longer than just
using regular nail glue but I think it's
so worth it to use the gel glue the last
hack is using food coloring to create a
DIY lip stain so you basically make this
beautiful long lasting stain for just a
few bucks and you can technically mix up
whatever color you want I just realized
that I accidentally bought the powder
version of food coloring and not the
little liquidy Drip Drop kind I think it
should still work exactly the same I
just have to check the measurements I
want to make something
pinky like leaning towards pink maybe a
little orange something in that area so
I'm going to add some water now to make
it a liquidy consistency ooh is that
is that what it's gonna look like on my
lips
it feels like nothing is going off
and it looks way more pigmented the more
I layered it so now it does look like
I'm wearing lipstick it doesn't look as
natural but I'm gonna try to wipe off
the excess and see if it looks a little
better once this sets for a second I
definitely like it a lot better now that
I rubbed some of the bright pink away it
looks a lot more natural and subtle it's
nice to know though that with this hack
you can kind of build your own
pigmentation if you want a brighter
color just add more if you want a more
subtle color just rub some away and it
works really really nicely I definitely
would add gloss on top of this I think
I'm going to but I just wanted to see
no transfer
so I'm going to wear this for the rest
of the day and then check in with you
guys later to show you how the color has
held up the stain has definitely faded
but I can still see it which is good my
lips feel a bit drier than normal which
I don't love but I feel like the food
coloring is a pretty good option if you
want a long lasting lip stain
[Music]